- Yeah and I, when I was younger,
my mom had told me that she used heroin,
my dad used heroin.
She told me, she told me and
I didn't understand it then,
she said over everything I would give,
I would give you up and your
little brother up for drugs
I would choose drugs over
you and your brother,
- [Interviewer] Your mom told you that?
- Yeah and she didn't mean that
to be mean or, or, or anything like that.
It's just the way drugs are.
- [Interviewer] All right, Josh.
Josh, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm from South Jersey,
right outside of Canyon,
about 10 minutes from
North Philly, Kensington.
- [Interviewer] So Kensington
is another community
similar to skid row, right?
- Yeah it's just about the same.
It was open air drug market,
there's a lot of homeless everywhere.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
How would you, how would
you compare the two?
- There's a lot of, there
are a lot of drugs out there.
You know, you get a drug on any block,
you can't even walk down the street
without being offered,
whatever you want, basically.
And honestly, it's an
oasis for drug addicts.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
and the police tend to leave you alone?
- Yeah they tend to leave you alone,
you don't really get bothered out there.
- [Interviewer] Right, yeah.
And how, how was your childhood?
- I would say, like,
I didn't grow up with my mom or my pops,
they're both, you know,
both addicted to drugs,
they're in and out of prison.
So I grew up, my grandfather raised me.
I was getting a lot of trouble, you know,
on probation at a young age
and getting into foster care
on like committed programs
and stuff like that.
Therapeutic communities.
And in jewelry, I just acted up a lot.
You know, got into drugs young,
just like everybody else
in Jersey, you know,
but you know,
I thought it was just what
we did it's in my blood.
Everybody does it, you know,
I thought it was normal.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- I'd say like--
- [Interviewer] Your family and all that?
- My grandfather raised me and my
it wasn't like he didn't show emotion.
So I wasn't like really connected to them.
You know, I was more like,
I felt separate, you know?
- [Interviewer] So your mom
and dad didn't raise you?
- No, no, no.
They were in a prison, you know?
So I didn't, I know them, you know,
I just never lived with them.
I never seen them together.
They got locked up when
I was really young.
So my dad's still in prison right now,
but you know
my mom uses drugs still,
but I grew to knewer a
lot, know her very well.
You know, she's been homeless
all over the country.
She's taught me,
she like, kinda like hippie,
like just taught me how to basically
how to be homeless and
how to appreciate people
and treat people when you're homeless
and just how to survive.
- [Interviewer] So you've
been living on the streets
for how long?
- Been on my own since I was basically 14,
in and out of programs.
Then 17 is when I got off of probation
and started traveling the
country when I was in Colorado
to see my moms, ended up in foster care.
After that I ended up
living on the streets
of Denver and caught a charge
right after I turned 18.
And I went on the run.
So I started working
at a carnival in Texas.
My mom hooked me up with
them to basically travel
with the carnival and like off papers.
So I could, I was on the
run from the cops basically.
And there's like, it's like
living on the streets there.
And we ended up back in
Denver and it's just cold.
It's too cold out there.
You know, I almost died
from just freezing to death.
You know, it was a foot
of snow on the ground
and it's like, you have to
get high, you have to drink,
you have to do something to stay warm.
You can't sleep at night
because you're shivering so bad.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
part of the reason I think
skid row is so populated is
because it's a climate that you can deal
with it for a lot of these people,
if you can make it to L.A.
then you can just survive on skid row
and everyone including the
police leave you alone.
- It's like, like I said,
your offered whatever you want.
It's not hard to find, you know, all my
I know a lot of people from out
of state to come out here
and this is where they go.
You know, I come out here
every day and you know,
I got like, I got a
lot of people out here.
I got a lot of friends out here.
- [Interviewer] What's your drug now?
- I do fentanyl every
day, every single day.
And crack, everyday, a lot of it.
- [Interviewer] What do
you spend a day on it?
- Me and my fiance go
through about a half ounce
in two, three days, quarter
ounce a day, maybe of fentanyl.
- [Interviewer] And that's how much?
- Well I mean I get pretty good prices
on it cause I sell drugs a little bit.
So anywhere from like,
get it for like an eight ball for 200
a quarter rounds for like
anywhere from like 250,
but I usually get like
a half ounce for 500,
600, people would try that
charges a lot more than that.
But I mean it's really prevalent out here.
I got a pretty decent
plugs on it, but it's just,
it's just a lot, you know,
there's a lot of people that have it.
A lot of people that do
it, but we do too much.
We do entirely too much.
- [Interviewer] Have you OD'd?
- Yeah I've OD'd, I've OD'd
a few times in my life.
First time I was a, I was 18 years old.
I was doing heroin in Philly
and I overdosed on that doing
shots of heroin on, on a bag.
Cause they'd stamped their bags out there.
It's called good luck.
It was called good luck.
Yeah I was in a coma after
that one, went into a coma,
I had pneumonia in the
hospital, it nearly killed me.
I was in at Temple Lung Center in Philly.
It was really bad pneumonia after that.
You know, I've tried getting sober a lot.
A lot of times I came
out here to California to go to rehab,
just like you know a lot of other people
that are from out of state
you know, it's just--
- [Interviewer] Is that
what brought you here?
- Yeah yeah.
That's what brought me here.
I know a lot of people out
here that came out here
for that and I really wanted
to be sober a lot of times.
I really thought like that was the answer
but it is, you know, it was
always with all respect like,
eventually that has to come.
But right now I've been doing
doing fentanyl every day
for more than a year.
And I'm actually scared.
Yeah last night was the first
time I've been been without
for as long as I've been without.
And it was like that I've been
able to get it every day, you know?
I was so sick last night.
- [Interviewer] But you
couldn't get it last night
because why?
- It's not like, I didn't
know the money for it.
It's just like nobody was
responding and I hadn't.
Yes nobody was responding.
It was, I fell asleep.
- [Interviewer] All
your connections were--
- Yeah, I lost, I lost my last phone,
and lost my girl's phone,
so all contacts--
- [Interviewer] So all
your contacts were gone?
- Yeah and I just lost an
iPad out here on skid row.
- [Interviewer] you lose things
on a daily basis out here.
- Yeah, absolutely do, absolutely do.
- [Interviewer] And living on the streets,
I mean that lifestyle works for you?
- Honestly for a certain
amount of time I enjoy it
because it's not like
because that's all I knew,
you know, since a young age,
I was either in institutions
or on the streets, you know,
I didn't know how to live a regular life.
Go to work everyday, pay your
bills, that type of stuff.
You know, since I came
out here to California,
after getting sober for a
while, I started living that.
But, and for me and my fiance,
I don't want that for us,
but I can go back on the
streets in an instant
and be perfectly fine.
- [Interviewer] It's what
you're used to is what you know.
Having a life with
responsibility and bills and rent
and all these kinds of things,
does it kind of scare you a bit?
- It not only scares me.
I don't know if I can handle it, you know?
Yeah I mean, I've been doing
all right, but it's the drugs,
always, everything goes away,
everything will go away,
everything that we have
booked up for so long,
it all goes away in the end.
You know, this is ground zero.
This is where you ended
up every single time,
no matter what.
- [Interviewer] You think
you'll end up spending
the rest of your life on,
in this kind of situation?
- Well I'm not lucky enough
to die from using fentanyl.
'Cause I was, once you
build a tolerance, you know,
there's no overdosing anymore,
no matter how you try,
it just doesn't work.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
So because your body has
built a tolerance to it
you can do more and more of it?
- Yeah I mean, you just do a lot.
I mean there's always a chance that like
you'll do the one shot
that'll kill you, but--
- [Interviewer] And is there a high still
from doing fentanyl?
- For a while, there, there isn't,
but there's like different
types of fentanyl,
there's carfentanil,
there's irregular fentanyl,
the dark burning stuff,
and that's more like a body high
it lasts a little bit longer
and I don't really get high from it, but--
- [Interviewer] You just need it?
- I need, I feel well from it.
But the carfentanil
knocks you out, you know,
it'll knock you out.
But no, I'm not really
scared of it anymore.
Like I used to, used to be, you know,
and there's times where I don't
I've almost, I probably
blackout every night.
Like if I stay up for a couple of days,
I won't know how, I'll go to sleep.
Me and my fiance will both pass out
and it's like a blacking
out at the end of the night
just passing out from
straight exhaustion, you know?
And when I wake up in a weird spot
like head between our legs on the ground,
laying with my dog
you know butts sticking up
in the air, weird spots, man.
It's not safe it's not okay.
But it's the life I'm used to.
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- [Josh] I'm 25.
- [Interviewer] 25.
No kids?
- [Josh] No, no kids.
I've been using drugs since I was young
I was shooting up since I
was 18, heroin, PCP, crack.
I've done it all, acid, you know.
- [Interviewer] What do you worry about?
- [Josh] What do I worry about?
- [Interviewer] What do
you worry about, yeah.
- [Josh] Biggest thing
I worry about is, is my,
my fiance, you know,
and trying to make her happy
and do what I can to keep her
okay you know.
- [Interviewer] Is it difficult
maintaining a relationship
or a romantic one where you're,
once you become a hardcore addict?
Your priorities change right?
Getting the fix becomes like
your first priority, right?
- No, it's true.
It's totally true.
Because you know, we, you know,
we've been blessed to where
we've been able to get it every day,
but there's that moment
in time when like that ship comes first.
- [Interviewer] I talked to
so many addicts who will give
up their kids, their health, their life,
their jobs, their careers, everything,
because the fix is more important.
- Yeah and I, when I was younger,
my mom had told me that she used heroin,
my dad used heroin.
She told me, she told me, and
I didn't understand it then,
she said, you know, over
everything I would give,
I would give you up.
And your little brother up for drugs
I would choose drugs over
you and your brother.
- [Interviewer] Your mom told you that?
- Yeah and she didn't mean that to be
to be mean or, or anything like that.
It's just the way drugs are.
You would choose a drug
over anything, you know,
and as strong as my morals,
as I want my morals to be as strong as I
as I want my, to maintain my
responsibilities and values,
eventually they go away.
Eventually drugs come first.
And then you stop taking,
my house is filthy.
You know and I'm a clean person.
I'm neat, I like to be neat,
I like a bed made, messy bed messy head,
but my house is filthy.
Dog piss on the ground,
sink full of fucking,
it's embarrassing,
I really shouldn't have said that but like
Just drugs come first sometimes.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
and you're a young man.
Where do you see your life going?
Like you're 25.
Where do you think you'll be at 35, 45?
Do you have any goals?
Do you have anything?
- I have tons of goals,
tons of aspirations still.
I'm glad I still do because
there's certain points
in time where I was going to kill myself.
I tried, you know, just,
I didn't see hope at all,
but you know, I see hope, you know,
if I can kick this shit hopefully
I'll try to maintain it
better, which never works.
And I have goals.
I have aspirations, I'd like
to go to college, you know,
me and my girl and stuff,
tried opening up a business,
you know, doing like re
homing fashion products,
like bags and belts and stuff like that.
Book Bags.
You know, we're trying to,
we're trying to do something
with our lives, you know,
but we Slack on it all because of drugs.
Drugs are coming in the way of all of it.
- [Interviewer] It seems to me like the,
the trap that drug addiction
becomes is you, you start
the drug for whatever reason,
you know trying to forget
about childhood traumas
or whatever.
But eventually it changes
your brain chemistry where
you'd no longer have the
wherewithal to resist the drug.
You get addicted.
And you, you just, you, you
can't fight it any longer.
- I can't.
Yeah I can't.
- [Interviewer] I've heard
so many heroin addicts
say I'd rather die than quit.
- It's scary.
I'm so scared to fucking
stop using fentanyl.
Honestly I'm scared.
'Cause I've used it every single day.
All day long.
I've never been without last
night was the first night.
That I've been without.
- [Interviewer] Your brain chemistry
gets so altered that you can't
you don't have what it takes
to fight it any longer.
- No, that's all.
That's all I can think about.
How the fuck am I going to get it?
- [Interviewer] And your day
revolves around it every day?
- Oh every day.
Maybe it's what I do every day.
- [Interviewer] Do you have to wake up
in the morning and have it ready for you?
- Oh yeah.
Me and her wake each other up.
And she's like, here, here's this,
and here's this crack
and feny, crack and feny.
Don't wake up without it.
- [Interviewer] What
does crack do for you?
- Crack keeps me awake
enough to manage, you know?
'Cause like I honestly I
with the Fetty what'd
you do is you lose your
your feeling of pleasure.
You don't feel pleasure
anymore from anything.
And crack gives you
thatfucking endorphin rush.
That, that that's a pleasure.
That's my pleasure.
You know?
But then there's a certain point where
you just do it all day long, constantly.
Like right now I don't
I don't wait this long to take crack
I don't even breathe almost.
That's how much I smoke crack.
It's kind of scary.
That's only because I've
been really blessed to be
in the situation I'm in,
I'm feeling very right now.
like I got to go at some point, you know,
I'd love to sit here
and talk like, this is,
I don't get to talk about
this stuff with people.
I don't get to be honest
about this stuff to people, you know?
'Cause it's embarrassing
and I might not look I'm
probably do now, but like I can,
I can hold my own in a conversation.
Most of the time at this point
I'm I'm getting strung out.
- [Interviewer] Is shame a big
part of what you experience?
- Shame, guilt, yeah.
You know I try not to intervene
in most people's lives to try to stay away
from people I'm trying to--
- [Interviewer] But if you had kids
and then they were being raised
by your mom or grandparent
or something like that
then there's that shame
on top of the other shame.
- Yeah I don't know
if I could have kids cause
I can't do that to my kids.
Like my family, my mom
and dad did that to me.
You know, I couldn't, I couldn't,
I would do the same thing
they did, fucking continue to use.
- [Interviewer] It just becomes a trap.
What's the most important
lesson you've learned?
- Most important lesson
I've learned is you just
can't use that one time, that first time,
the first time you think it's okay
you think you can just can control it.
You think it's going to be different.
It's not, ends up here every single time,
ends it back here every single time.
I thought I had my shit together.
I thought I had a place, the Benz,
crashed the Benz, you know,
maybe rather lose the place.
And here I am on a skid row.
- [Interviewer] Alright, Josh,
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- [Josh] Of course man.
I wish you the best of luck.
- [Josh] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.
- [Josh] Mhm, of course.